try one more okay if let's suppose it
was alive instead of 2x looks like an
x-squared
hmm just for the sake of it you just to
make it a little bit easier off let's
let's just make it a pear tree because
we're gonna illustrate something with
this example in a second
no actually we want to expand okay let's
just try we've been doing so far okay
capital F right power goes up right so x
squared plus 1/3 yeah divide by the new
power now well sorry Phi this is what
we've been doing okay
derivative of the inside right give me
the inside okay so I get this huge 6x
okay just for the sake of it I'm gonna
expand this out this is why I pick 3
rather than hundred okay because I'm not
haha I'm interested in you know
finishing this before the Sun Goes Down
so let's do the expansion finish okay
now eventually you'll learn how to how I
do this so quickly without actually
doing it the top of steps yes it is what
we do by the way up there but this is
gonna be let's see X to the six plus
three X to the 4/3 x squared okay now if
you like you can go ahead and you can do
x squared plus 1 and then x squared plus
one squared and here you go and do it
but you could or you could just drop it
that's what you're gonna end up with
okay let's just do this going one more
step so X 6 divided by 6 X that's going
to be X to the 5 on 6 alright this is
going to become x cubed 2x - okay no
when you look at this right
is there anything suspicious about this
if you're unusual does it look like it's
a plausible answer hmm now when I look
at it right
it starts off looking pretty okay right
because when you look at this thing the
whole thing ought to be sorry
well now look at this the whole thing
should be a power of four so now when I
ng differentiate right I should end up
with power of five so that looks like it
checks out and then you know this
expansion sort of looks okay then you
get to this guy now why might that be a
problem why might that set off alarm
bells be actually it's not that fast
think about this right i anteye
differentiated right and so this is
where I ended up okay but we don't this
come from which of these terms right
because I can actually spend this that's
not that hard right
which of these when I add to
differentiate it turns into this hmm
yeah let's just keep that there for a
second
suppose rather try and do it a short
time we actually did expand it out what
would happen okay let's expand this out
it's not a difficult expansion to do X
square plus one all swim it's going to
be one X to the fourth the front plus
two squared plus one
okay now let's hear to differentiate is
power up divide power divide now you can
see superficially they are similar you
still want the 5 4 3 2 X but then what
what happens now which one is right now
I'm going to suggest that they are not
they can't both be right
ok here is why if you've been looking at
quadratic identities at the end of last
year okay when you've got you know it
next to the fives and X cubes and that
kind of thing there's going to be a
fifth of an exit to the fire yeah and
there are no other x to the fives
anywhere else here right in the same way
there are no idiom there are no other X
to the 5 over here so there's nothing
that can you know make this 6 turn into
a 5 right these are irreconcilably
different okay I can't turn one into the
other and the clincher is really this
guy this guy has no parallel at all over
here okay I met an excellent one okay so
how can I tell which one is right can we
say that one's right when we say this
one is right yes because is there some
strange rule that we don't know that I'm
just there a strange rule that means you
can't aunty differentiation rules which
is actually some sense in there I think
if I guess somewhere being you're pretty
wearing it right now which one is right
now
is a real way you can tell which one's
right or not that's that's true that's
true
that's weird though isn't it right let's
go after that because it's not gonna
it's not gonna help us work out the
right answer but it is gonna tell us
that there's problems in this one okay
this function what does it look like you
could actually make some guesses as to
what it looks like right so it's gonna
be something like that it's it's a
quartic for some time okay now when you
look at it right if you're going to the
primitive okay that means this is the
derivative of this function okay but the
derivative exists everywhere there's no
value of x you can put into it which
which breaks it okay but this this
doesn't exist everywhere as Justin SIPP
doesn't exist at x equals zero I'm gonna
have some asymptotes here right so
where's the acetone on this derivative
like when you have a when you have a the
derivative of something which behaves at
some type of a should go off to infinity
right but this is just behaving pretty
normally pretty close I don't know where
its intercessor because I haven't I
suspect it has no innocence because back
to zero now the way to really know which
one is right or not
it's a different shape okay so let's
give each one okay let's let's take a
let's take this one could we go first
and let's just well it should be all of
these steps 1 2 3 4 if I did my algebra
right shouldn't matter which step by
different unit because they all should
be the same okay so which one should I
do
actually I mean we can choose any one
these are all the same
well this one this this is a question
should I differentiate this what should
i differentiate this which one do you
think would be easier why can't we have
I suggest the the bottom one probably
because because I know my question rule
I just don't like for sure I'll actually
haven't tested it out maybe it would be
quite simple but this one because power
is really easy to work with
okay let's differentiate do we X to the
5 or 6 what does it become 6 right
differentiation set board ok it's cute
right - ok yes
that's just 1/2 what's this guy become
that's a 6 X to the minus 1 X to the
minus 2 that's on the bottom and then
the constant disappears okay now does
this look like I could factorize it and
twist it so could turn into that yeah
these the fractions just get worse and
worse right I'm into the powerful this
guy this guy where you gonna put him
right yeah all right let's try this one
instead
okay let's different communities okay
and you can already start to see right
next to the 5 the 5 gonna come out the
front and then cancel like so right and
the 3 is going to come out the front and
cancel so you're gonna get 3 times 2x
squared on 3 since what yet the 3s
cancel this just becomes one constant
disappears and that's looking pretty
convinced
to be sir therefore what have we
concluded okay um this slide here
specifically this step this burgers okay
so this reverse chain rule right you
have to be careful you can't simply
divide through by this is see this step
here we divided by the derivative of the
inside okay you can't just divide
through by anything right it's a bit
like constants right we can we can muck
around with this so the derivative of
for instance 5x is the same as five
times the derivative of X okay right do
five inches five five times one that's
that's all good right so being that we
can do that we can move closer to round
we can take them in and out and we can
multiply we divide or we can multiply
that's okay right but once the X's come
into it hmm other rules seem to take
care about okay so if you see something
like this you still need to expand down
okay we're gonna we're gonna deal with
guys like this a bit later there's
another platter of rest painful that we
have to learn but it's it's for any kind
of X if I'm not just multiplying or
dividing through by a constant I'm in
trouble
okay